para la eurocámara Hungría ha dejado de
ser una democracia plena la eurocámara
con más de 400 votos a favor considera
que ahora mismo Hungría el país liderado
por Víctor orman Es un régimen híbrido
de autocracia electoral es decir que hay
un sistema electoral constitucional con
elecciones pero que no se respetan ni
las normas ni los principios básicos de
una democracia de hecho para el
parlamento europeo el gobierno húngaro
está socavando de forma deliberada con
esfuerzos reales para no cumplir todas
estas normas y principios democráticos y
ponen como ejemplo los problemas en la
independencia judicial en la corrupción
también en la falta de libertad de
prensa o incluso la persecución o las
personas de la comunidad lgtbi y también
a refugiados a migrantes incluso de
minoría étnica por todo ello el
parlamento europeo considera que Hungría
debe ser sancionada Si no cumple con
Estos principios y no acometer reformas
precisamente la comisión europea está
preparando para este domingo una
propuesta para congelar los fondos
europeos si Hungría no cumple con todos
los principios y no hace verdaderos
cambios especialmente en cuanto a la
corrupción